hallo mein name ist luca und ich habe ja
schon mal die treue fans chris gespielt
davon gibt es anscheinend auch einen
teil 2 deswegen habe ich mir gedacht
publikum einfach mal auf play und worauf
lasse ich mich hier immer ein wir lassen
uns davon natürlich nicht beirren und
klicken einfach mal auf start und können
dann hier mal drauf klicken und
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich jetzt hier machen kann
man sein kind sieht aus wie alles klar
alles klar
hasler alles klar komme ich nehme das
tombola
was soll ich tun kann ich mit ihnen ihr
[Musik]
was soll das ich glaube ich kann hier
noch gar nichts machen nicht immer
wieder zurück und okay doch ich muss da
wohl rein ich verstehe das nicht ich
klicke auf ihn nicht raus linie auf
weniger auf in ihr nichts passiert
[Musik]
die habe ich das getan
okay wir sind jetzt hier bei einem super
duper vip nightclub wir sehen so aus als
hätte mich übelst poker party was
passiert wenn ich auf mich drauf alles
klar wenn ihr euch fragt wie es aussieht
wenn lukan club gehen will
[Musik]
womit kann ich denn hier so interagieren
nicht könnte der fall ist das einzige
was ich machen kann es war sie auf mich
drauf klicken und weggetreten werden ich
verstehe das gar nicht ich kann die auto
warten
hier oben ist irgendwie kann ich barack
obama beim nächsten level geht darum
dass ich wieder einmal viele wo kann ich
denn noch draufklicken ich kann hier
auch ging
oh sorry amthor diese kamera drei füße
und die sieht aus wie ein ganz ruhig
kann ich auf seinen hof gehen wie ich
dann lacht er nur gehen was ist wenn ich
auf die lampe oben dann sterbe ich und
wenn ich das überblicke dann sterbe ich
und wenn ich hier drauf dann sterbe ich
und kann ich nicht ich verstehe das gar
nicht
[Musik]
ich konnte die augen verschließen ich
bin der vogel auf einem teleskop und ok
ich hab' den jetzt auf z und wenn ich
jetzt hier drauf brücke dann ist das
level wohl irgendwie gefehlt jetzt habe
ich das auf dem außen verzeichnen wenn
ich jetzt schaustücke und 3 und schaue
dann ist das level selbstverständlich
auch gefällt kann ich nicht irgendwie
wenn ich das ausrufezeichen hat das
jetzt noch mal ändern alles oder
elektrischen hätte ich muss doch
irgendwie auf den mond schicken können
umspringt so einfach kann es geht in der
badi star und damit wieder den vogel der
ist auch in duschen dieses horn duschen
und das war heißt wenn ich drauf klicken
dann jetzt zu kalt kann ich mich
irgendwie dann ich muss also ein
mittelding finden die beim beim vogel
irgendwie hat oder kann ich deine augen
wieder schließen oder hier seinen links
wegpacken ich muss doch irgendwie
einfach so ein mittelweg finden damit
der normal duschen kann eigentlich lohnt
es sich echt wenn man einfach mit der
maus so komplett durch bild
durchgedrückt haben alles ab tat sind
weil also nee das war der der komiker
haken hier dann müsste es doch
eigentlich klappen ich meine man kann
doch nur mit sachen internet gehen wo
die maus wirklich so zum dings wird man
danach punkt
dieses spiel ist sowas von viel schwerer
als die erste troll facebook ich
verlinke ihr euch mal darüber am kopf
von balu da ist die erste trophäe
wir machen weiter mit dem spiel auch
durch den kurz vorm abgrund alter kann
ich bin tot wenn ich hier auf den armen
brücke dann fällt er auch bunter und was
ist wenn ich kann ich nicht mit ihm hier
dann falle ich werde wahrscheinlich auch
runter was ist ja nicht auf die leine ok
dann weil ich auch und da kann ich mich
auch was ist man muss so krass aufpassen
auf diesem auf diesem spiel
hier muss ich irgendwie am flughafen
durch die kontrolle durch den bin
komplett
[Musik]
ok hier kann ich nicht irgendwie ihnen
dadurch schicken und jetzt mit dem das
hat nicht geklappt oder kann ich ihm
einfach seine das hat auch nicht
geklappt diesen typen dahin besprechen
ach guck mal hier
das mache ich ihnen hier durch und jetzt
habe ich gefehlt ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung was ich mit den knöpfen
machen muss aber kann er nicht einfach
man was ist denn das für ein scheiß
spiel der typ hier muss irgendwie auch
dieses laufbahn drauf damit der und ich
sollte es dass man dort denken die
letzte quest für heute ist das hier
warum ist nur so gemein alter ich kann
mit jedem scheiß hinter agieren da oben
ist wieder der vogel hier alle sind
wir haben es geschafft das hühnchen da
oben ist tot wenn ich hier runter
springen bin ich auch tot und der
helikopter hier kann auch nicht hörten
hängig inhalte tochter hoch stecken und
dann bin ich tot acht guck mal ich
konnte ihn von oben nach unten bewegen
die einen level muss ich noch mal dass
man dann weil wir zu viel spaß ich muss
wohl irgendwie die gleichen finden
da haben wir dann machen wir da machen
wir hier so dann machen wir hier und da
und das ist doch ich habe alles gezockt
damit es nicht klappt ich hasse dieses
spiel